[Music]
right welcome to puerto rico one of the
most extraordinary incredible islands
i've ever had a chance to visit i'm
going to show you a local um it's a
beautiful dish used with leftover rice
it's called pigal and it's going to be
done almost like a sticky rice in a cast
iron so the secret is beautiful sausage
i've got some cooked chicken here first
now this is about how do you elevate
that how do you lift that to the next
level now the beauty of this dish is
that it's a staple
nothing fancy
but the flavor profile is unique and i
mean unique
slice up the onions
not too thin
otherwise they burn
whilst i do that
take your these are leftover roasted uh
chicken
take them
lightly season them
okay and just get them into the cast
iron pan i want to get that really nice
and crispy over to the pan
nothing in there just straight on
and get them nice and crispy i want the
chicken fat coming off there i'll show
you why in a minute super crispy really
important
now
with the onions get some garlic
slice that down
be generous in the garlic
take some of this sausage and all we do
there is just literally take that out
and squeeze that over
get rid of the casing
and that's a beautiful puerto rican
spicy sausage was going to give a really
nice flavor
to the rice now that may not look
advertising but trust me it will
transform into something unique let me
tell you
now got the color on the chicken
take that out
and then
with the onions
sausage garlic in
over we go
i've got that flavor of that chicken in
there already look beautiful
oil in
now your onions
and your garlic and your sausage goes in
now try that off beautiful
now i get that really nice and crispy
great color on the sausage
great color on the onions caramelise
that garlic
and start to make this really nice and
flat now base
from there
take your salt
and give that
a really good seasoning
beautiful
beautiful
really important that you keep that on
the heat
and it starts getting really nice and
caramelized remember we're going to
crisp the rice so you never ever get
anything crispy in a cold pan so keep
that heat in there
flatten that down nicely
leave that bubbling away
now the chicken
skin as well just open that up
and sort of
break it in half
and literally keep it nice and sort of
chunky not too small you want that all
sort of coming off the bone
get it too small
and it sort of disintegrates you want
those nice
chunks of chicken running through this
dish i'm using all the skin as well such
great flavor
and look at that got a bit of spice in
there
got the caramelization going on there
that's exactly where i want to get that
now
in with that chicken
beautiful
that is
beautiful
once all that's fried off
from there
take that out
get our pan really nice and hot again
look at that how beautiful is that
and now we're going to start frying the
rice
really beautiful the flavor in there is
incredible now
oil goes in really important to get that
oil piping hot okay
and that's going to help literally get
that rice nice and sticky and this is
the sear that's super important
okay
here she goes
you tip four
now from there
just literally
pat that down
and get that
super crispy
really important to get the rice so
toasty
almost in a way that you think you've
overcooked it but it's not it's a smart
way of doing it
next
get my chicken over
spread that in there with the onions and
the sausage
get all that
resting juice
beautifully done
but that
just looks incredible chicken is nice
and crispy onions have done their job
the sausage has rendered
the spices come out those
and it really is literally making that
sing
push that down be disciplined pat that
chicken into that rice and get that
crispy
now the garnish are the eggs
just a beautiful fried egg on top of
there okay so
non-stick pan
and that over
i'm gonna flavor the eggs
with a little touch of garlic in there
beautiful
a little bit of the
pepper
again just down
again local pepper a little bit of heat
to the eggs
i just want to
run that through that oil
so beautiful
fry that off
get that nice and crispy before we crack
our eggs in there a touch of salt
now get that oil nice and hot once you
start softening the garlic and the
peppers
get a touch of butter in there
and just to get this really nice and
brown now i'm going to put a touch of
butter down the side
of the rice
let's give that a really nice nut brown
flavor
and so that starts getting nice and
toasty
underneath that beautiful caramelized
rice the butter
literally lifts the flavor
now once that butter melts
get your eggs
straight in
over the garlic such a beautiful way of
cooking eggs
and start getting them fried
the flavor those peppers and the garlic
go into the eggs
then we'll hit that with some cilantro
roll that round use the stove to your
advantage
cilantro now
get some beautiful
cilantro
group it up
and literally
cover those eggs
without cilantro
watch this
so nice
over
beautifully
so on there we'll tip that out for
flavor
i'm just cooking the whites
that is nice and crispy
over
and now for the exciting part
get the plate
carefully
sit that on top
and then we'll turn that down
and literally
bang and just to be sure
and then
lift that
off
beautiful
wow
take your eggs
and
i'm using garlic and peppers
and there we have the most amazing
puerto rican
pagal
beautiful
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch it on catch
up on disney plus
foreign